if you've clicked on this video thinking
i'm talking about bimx or that it's a
pure clickbait title
it's definitely not
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas welcome back to the channel
if you're new here thank you so much for
joining me on this channel we talk about
technology
and more so nowadays architecture if
that's something that interests you
make sure you smash that subscribe
button 20 20 style and let's get today's
video so today we're talking about how
you can run
mac os or even windows operating systems
on your ipad 100 legit
no click bait now the reason i came to
this kind of
research trail was more so for the fact
that i was on site thinking how can i
get archicad on my ipad how can i make
it work
how can i show clients or how can i just
figure out the bits and pieces that
haven't been put into the early stages
of the sketch drawings
it genuinely led me down a pretty big
rabbit hole but it came to a conclusion
which is very powerful and a great way
to implement archicad on your ipad
now having said that there are some
limitations to it which i will get into
later down the video now in the last
video i did promise to move around the
house a lot more
and give you guys all sorts of different
backgrounds to really keep
the videos fresh unfortunately a couple
days ago
i completely ruptured my achilles tendon
and i'm on crutches and in a cast
so i'm not moving around too fast but i
am committing
to my one video a week every monday so
if that doesn't deserve a like and
subscribe i don't know what does
now enough beating around the bush let's
get to what you're actually here for
the app i'm talking about is called utm
and i'll link it down below
utm is a virtual emulator that allows
you to
emulate any mac os or windows operating
system
on any device so if you have
for example an ipad or an iphone you can
run
mac os on either device now obviously on
an ipad pro it's going to run a lot
quicker than it's going to run on an
old iphone what you need to understand
is utm
is not an app store supported app which
means you can't go and freely download
this app
and really nearly start using any
operating system
unfortunately you do need to side load
it in which means your ipad or iphone
doesn't need to be jailbroken it can be
running
the latest ios system on it and you can
install it
somewhat legally apple doesn't condone
this app in any way shape or form so if
you do download it and do use it
make sure that it is at your own
personal risk if for some reason it does
corrupt your ipad or your iphone your
warranty will not cover this because
it's a third party
side loaded app there is a bit of a
process to installing this it's all gone
through on the website if you're
interested you as you'll find out later
down this video
i don't actually recommend trying this
whatsoever so if i've already told you i
wouldn't recommend it i've probably
given it away
what's the catch really the catch is
pretty simple
it's an emulator it runs windows and mac
os
but from a very very dated version for
example mac os
is only running 10.5 leopard
or you can run windows xp or windows 7.
knowing those facts it means you can
only run archicad 14
on the ipad os or if you decide to run
the windows version instead of the mac
version you can actually bump it up to
archicad 19.
the second catch is very simple here it
does not support
directx or opengl graphic card supports
so even though your ipads and your
iphones have their own internal graphics
capabilities
this software isn't able to harness that
power and isn't able
to use it to actually run graphics
performance
programs so for another example if
you're trying to play high-end video
games on this emulator
or if you're trying to really really
push out high-end
3d rendering there's absolutely no way
it'll work
archicad is good enough to load up and
boot up
but that's probably about the extent of
it you can maybe get into a page or two
before it decides to crash
and completely be useless because it has
no graphics functionality you can't open
the 3d versions of your models you can't
really
dive in depth like you can in bimx so
overall bimx is still a better and more
capable product
but it's nice to know that you can
actually
install and run archicad on an ipad if
you're extremely extremely desperate
and for some reason 10 10 or so versions
behind
i don't think many people are going to
be running archicad 14
still on their main primary desktop so
you can't run arcade 24
you can't run the latest revit 2020 you
basically can't do anything
to keep up with modern technology so why
even make a video about it
and tell you guys that it's possible but
at the same time
it isn't there yet well that's kind of
the whole point
it is possible and within the next
couple of years i truly do believe that
we will see
maybe a view only version of our pln
files
that we'll be able to view and
manipulate inside an ipad
and then be able to progress further and
further as technology
becomes more advanced and it's probably
going to be the exact same thing for
many high-end
graphics intensive programs so any video
game you can think of any rendering
software you can think of
there's a good likelihood that in the
next five to ten years
it's going to be all able to run off
your ipad or even
off your smartphone so why did i
previously say i don't recommend
installing utm
well one it's not supported by apple so
if anything goes wrong your warranty is
null and void
two it's not on the app store and it
probably never will be on the app store
so it is a very time consuming process
to install it
for a very risky outdated software
so the emulators are running leopard and
windows 7.
that's geez almost a decade ago
that we were running those software on
our primary devices
and finally without the graphics
capabilities there's kind of no real
point
of being able to run a really outdated
version of archicad or really
outdated version of whatever you're
trying to open on your ipad
because the files you've created on your
main
desktop or whatever your primary working
device is
are going to be so far advanced and not
backwards capable
to 2010 or whenever the software
was actually announced and released so
theoretically
yes you can run archicad on an ipad in
practice
probably not the most useful thing to be
spending your time on
figuring out how to load it on there and
figuring out
the nitty-gritty of going back 10
versions ago anyway that's all for me
today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash the like and
subscribe button and as always
i'll see you next monday